I'm here at CES unveiled and I found
this cool little gadget it's called the
empower peg that's short for personal
energy generator and it's like a little
dynamo that you put in your pocket now
it's got a spring and a weight and some
other stuff inside so it turns motion
into electrical energy you can actually
shake it like this and kind of do a
little infomercial action if you want
but you don't actually have to do that
the way it's meant to be used is you put
it in your backpack or in your pocket I
guess and as you walk around during the
day the motion of your body just
naturally generates energy it's got a
battery inside and as that battery fills
up it's got power that you can use to
recharge your iPhone there's a little
connector here that connects to an
adapter that you can plug in to your
phone you get about a minute of power
for every 15 to 30 minutes of walking
that you do an iPhone takes a lot more
power but if you're running something
small like an iPod nano you actually get
about a minute of power for every minute
you're walking so it could run your nano
indefinitely because it's got a battery
inside you can also charge up the
battery with the USB cable and then use
it Canova's reserve battery power if you
want the N power peg costs about $160
and you can order it now from an power
peg com for $160 it's a little pricey
for me especially since it doesn't
generate enough power to keep my iPhone
going all day but it is a first
generation product there's a lot of
potential here and who knows if you got
kids you could strap one to one of them
and probably power half the city block